Okay, I am going to give you video now of
two absolutely bonkers speeches.
I guess I'm hesitating to even call them speeches,
public events at which Trump said things over
the Fourth of July weekend.
Now, from the from the perspective of rallies,
Donald Trump has decided he's doing rallies.
He did the rally in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
We've already started to see cases rise and
rise and rise in the surrounding areas.
The rally itself was just an absolute, absolutely
disgusting combination of red meat and dog
whistles and fear mongering combined with
lies.
And Donald Trump was determined to keep it
going.
So on July 3rd, Donald Trump did an event
at Mount Rushmore, and this was one where
social distancing would not be allowed.
They actually zip tied the chairs together.
So people were not able to spread the chairs
apart.
There was barely a mask in sight.
And unfortunately, after all of this buildup,
this was one of Donald Trump's worst speeches.
And again, I sort of grimace said, even calling
it that incredibly low energy.
This was what we're calling, remember, upper
and Downer Trump.
I'm now calling it Adderall Trump and Benzodiazepine
Trump.
This was benzodiazepine Trump, a very, very
low energy Trump glitching noticeably multiple
times, uncertain words, which I will play
for you, kind of doing stream of consciousness
type stuff.
It was the verbal equivalent of an inkblot
or roar shock test, maybe the best way to
describe it.
Extremely sweaty, gripping his lectern, a
white knuckling it.
The audience was relatively low energy.
So let's go through some of this stuff.
We're gonna start with the glitches and Donald
Trump's trouble speaking.
There was a lot of it.
He had a major glitch on Jefferson.
If you're watching this, you'll see him verbally
catch on the word Jefferson and his right
shoulder twitches again and he seems to do
something very, very odd.
Let's take a look at it a couple of times.
Thomas Jefferson, the great Thomas Jefferson,
Thomas Jefferson, the great Thomas Jefferson.
So let's pick it up right after that.
Trump was mentioning Thomas Jefferson essentially
to start reading Thomas Jefferson's biography
in total monotone.
Very, very weird part of the speech.
Take a look.
Thomas Jefferson, the great Thomas Jefferson,
was 33 years old when he traveled north to
Pennsylvania.
And brilliantly authored one of the greatest
treasures of human history, the Declaration
of Independence.
He also drafted Virginia's constitution and
conceived and wrote the Virginia Statute for
Religious Freedom.
Just bizarre.
Right.
I mean, it sounds like Trump is reading Jefferson's
wiki bio off of the off of a prompter.
The crowd doesn't care.
More importantly, reading Thomas Thomas Jefferson's
biography has nothing to do with Trump's failed
governance or policy or anything like it.
Trump later mangling the word totalitarianism,
calling it totalitarian TISM.
Take a look at that.
This is the very definition of totalitarianism
and it is completely alien to our culture
and to our values.
And it has absolutely no place in the United
States of America.
Trump, again, going with Ulysses S. Grant,
of course, still can't say that one.
Take a listen.
Ulysses S. Grant, abolitionists and many others.
And this was actually part of Trump just naming
people.
This was, remember, during 2015 and 2016 at
his rallies.
Trump would just read polls.
Now, Trump just naming people during his events.
We are the country of Andrew Jackson.
Ulysses S. Grant and Frederick Douglass.
We are the land of Wild Bill Hickock and Buffalo
Bill Cody.
We are the nation that gave rise to the Wright
brothers, the Tuskegee Airmen.
Harriet Tubman, that went on for a while,
I'm not going to play all of it, more struggle's
talking, continued, struggling with magnificent,
struggling with mountain.
Take a look at this.
Be no better place to celebrate America's
independence than beneath this magnificent,
incredible, majestic mountain monument to
the greatest Americans who have ever lived.
OK, so a lot of difficulty speaking is the
point.
Let's now get into the meat and the content
of this.
There's this new strategy that Donald Trump
is employing during his public events.
Pretend that the left is some kind of Marxist
fascist nightmare.
Take a look at this.
And again, very low energy.
What he's saying is crazy, but he's delivering
it in this benzodiazepine sort of mode, schools,
our newsrooms, even our corporate boardrooms.
There is a new far left fascism that demands
absolute allegiance.
If you do not speak its language, performance
rituals, recite its mantras and follow its
commandments.
Then you will be censored, banished, blacklisted,
persecuted and punished.
It's not going to happen to us.
Make no mistake.
This Left-Wing Cultural Revolution is designed
to overthrow the American Revolution.
In so doing, they would destroy the very civilization
that rescued billions from poverty, disease,
violence and hunger.
And that lifted humanity to new heights of
achievement, discovery and progress to make
this possible.
They are determined to tear down every statue.
Symbol in memory of our national heritage.
So low energy seems to be on downers.
And the content Cultural Revolution, talking
about the left wants to overthrow the American
Revolution.
You want to make the United States just an
offshoot and belong to the United Kingdom.
I don't see any leftists who want to do that.
And just imagine for a second if a President
Barack Obama or another Democratic president
gave a speech about fighting the extreme right
wing and referenced defeating Nazis in World
War Two and fighting the Cold War or whatever.
As if that's what's going on today.
If a Democratic president did the equivalent
of what Donald Trump is doing here about Marxism
and people who want to undo the American Revolution,
Fox News and Rush Limbaugh and Hannity and
Tucker and all of them, they would be going
insane for a week.
That's essentially what Trump is doing.
And you have right wing pseudo intellectuals
like Rich Lowry saying this was a great speech.
If you can believe that monuments, OK, we've
learned that Donald Trump's staff want him
to talk less about monuments because they
see it as kind of a losing approach.
And again, Trump going on and on here about
monuments.
He also sounds like he's sleep talking now.
It's more like Ambien, like it's weird.
Trump gives an applause line.
The audience is almost silent.
So Trump just waits and finally gets some
some reaction from the crowd.
It's all very weird.
Our nation is witnessing a merciless campaign
to wipe out our history, to fame, our heroes,
a race, our values and indoctrinate our children.
Angry mobs are trying to tear down statues
of our founders to face our most sacred memorials
and unleash a wave of violent crime in our
cities.
Many of these people have no idea why they're
doing this, but some know exactly what they
are doing.
They think the American people are weak and
soft and submissive, wipe out history and
erase our values.
How would taking down Confederate statues
erase our values?
I didn't think our values were the values
of the Confederacy.
But maybe among Donald Trump supporters, those
values are more common than than maybe I believe.
Living in Massachusetts, Trump then still
seems not to understand the basics of how
a virus works.
He talks about killing the virus.
Of course, viruses are not actually alive.
Let us also send our deepest thanks to our
wonderful veterans, law enforcement, first
responders and doctors, nurses and scientists
working tirelessly to kill the virus.
They are working hard.
Yeah.
So on their own.
Viruses can do nothing until they enter a
living cell block without cells.
Viruses would not be able to multiply.
So viruses are not considered living things.
Trump talks about killing the virus.
Who cares?
Right.
It's the least of our concerns.
If Trump took Corona virus seriously, I wouldn't
care if he thought the virus was a hybrid
of a giraffe and a shark.
I really wouldn't like if he was actually
dealing with it properly and taking it seriously.
He happens not to be.
And then lastly, here's another just super
low energy part where I guess Trump is criticizing
Democrats.
It's not even clear what the critique is.
I guess they're not for law and order or something.
And he says kids are taught to hate their
country.
And cities that are run by liberal Democrats
in every case is the predictable result of
years of extreme indoctrination and bias in
education, journalism and other cultural institutions
against every law of society and nature.
Our children are taught in school to hate
their own country and to believe that the
men and women who built it.
We're not heroes, but that were villains.
So the audience just barely engaging with
what Donald Trump is saying.
And this was not the only horrifying Gong
Show speech that Donald Trump gave over the
weekend.
This was July 3rd in Mt. Rushmore.
On July 4th.
Donald Trump gave, I guess, what we're calling
his big Fourth of July speech.
And that's what I want
to talk
about next.